so the next time you get your hair
colored you need to make sure of
something
let me explain there are over 5,000 or
more chemicals that are put on our skin
on a regular basis from lotions to women
using makeup to all sorts of things are
the surface of our skin is like a sponge
it's a fat layer and they use certain
oils and you put on your skin it goes
right in like a rocket ship
and it has a cumulative effect it builds
up over time for hair dyes you have
ammonia parabens PPD's which is a toxic
chemical toluene and formaldehyde okay
which is gonna completely dry dry out
your skin so these chemicals can go in
the body and they can build up all the
name of looking beautiful right these
can have an effect of increasing the
risk of certain types of cancer
follicular lymphoma chronic lymphocytic
leukemia and other types of cancer so
the next time you go to your hairdresser
make sure they use something that is
organic that is a lot less toxic okay
there's all sorts of natural versions of
this I'm gonna put some links down below
and if he or she is not using this I
would HIGHLY encourage them to use this
and show them this video now the other
question and the flipside is like what's
going on with graying hair why are we
losing the color of our hair well what's
happening as we age we lose certain
antioxidants in our body and then we
have an excess of oxidants and one being
hydrogen peroxide and that's kind of
like a bleach it's gonna bleach out the
color pigment of your hair and leave it
a lighter color there are some things
that you can take potentially to improve
the situation it's not a hundred percent
it's I'm not even say it's gonna be
fifty percent maybe forty percent
effective because not everyone responds
to this but here's a list of things that
you may want to consider catalase is an
enzyme to help break down hydrogen
peroxide you can get this as a
supplement it works for some people
glutathione is a real a master
antioxidant that are
body mix and you can also take it as
well externally to help reduce hydrogen
peroxide and selenium which is very very
important if by itself is an antioxidant
and coconut well you can rub that into
the pores or your hair and it actually
can greatly help as well and the last
point I want to bring up is that this
doesn't just go for your hair dyes it
goes for your makeup your lotions and
the other things that you put in the
surface of your skin so look at the
ingredients find some brand that is a
lot less toxic because it does
accumulate in your body all right I'll
talk to you soon hey guys real quick I
have a new healthy keto eating plan for
you just go to dr. Berg comm it's right
on the front page I put a link down
below download it it's free check it out